[Música]
Olá,
meus amigos, minhas amigas. Sejam muito
bem-vindos para mais uma live.
É um prazer estar aqui com vocês.
Temos seis perguntas hoje, então vou
responder com bastante grau de
detalhamento essas perguntas e depois
nós vamos discutir um artigo que ficou
devendo da semana passada.
À medida que vocês forem entrando, por
favor, vão se identificando, vão dando o
seu alô e a primeira pessoa aí que puder
me dizer se o áudio está legal, seria
bem interessante.
Bem, a primeira pergunta
é a respeito de uma situação que a
pessoa coloca aqui uns exames
laboratoriais
e eu digo para vocês, por favor, evitem
de mandar casos clínicos
como se fosse uma consulta médica, tá?
Porque isso daí é uma situação que me
deixa
em maus lençóis, eticamente falando, né?
que a pessoa tentar, digamos assim,
obter uma consulta informal, tá? Mas
vamos lá.
A pessoa, no caso, diz que tem um LDL em
204, HDL 75, triglicerides 70 e
homostena de 11,3.
Parece que é uma pessoa de 66 anos que
tem esses números e faz atividade física
quatro vezes por ano.
Então, a pergunta é sobre se esses
exames estariam dentro de limites
aceitáveis,
que que eu recomendaria?
Então, analisando esse perfil lipídico,
estão repetindo,
é um colesterol
LDL de 204, HDL de 75, trigide 69.
Deixa eu ver se eu perdi algum detalhe
que parece que essa pergunta tá um pouco
incompleta.
Não é essa pergunta mesmo, não. Parece
que cortou alguma coisa na pergunta,
mas enfim. E analisando esse perfil
lipídico e metabólico pela perspectiva
da medicina funcional,
a minha preocupação principal desses
números seria em relação à homisteína
que tá acima de 10, tá? Porque a relação
triglicérides HDL é de 0,92, que é uma
relação boa, abaixo de um.
A gente considera risco aumentado quando
esses valores estão acima de dois, tá? A
relação triglicérides HDL. Então isso
indica o quê?
predominância de partículas de LDL
grandes, né? Grandes e
que a gente chama de fluffy ou
fofinhas, né? E essas partículas são
muito menos aterogênicas. Så
Vocês
estão me vendo? Porque a internet daqui
caiu.
Ficamos aí uns 5 minutos sem internet
por conta de um pico que deu aqui. Está
chovendo e você sabe como é que é a rede
elétrica de São Paulo? Não pode cair uma
gota de água.
Ã,
bem, vamos começar tudo de novo, tá?
Parece que o Eliseu tá me escutando,
então vamos lá. É uma pessoa de 66 anos
que tem o LDL colesterol de 204, HDL de
75, triglicéri de 70 e ostena de 11.
Como eu disse, em relação ao perfil
lipídico e metabólico dessa pessoa, ela
tem uma relação triglicides HDL boa de
0,92 e qualquer número abaixo de dois é
favorável, porque indica a predominância
partículas de LDL grandes e fofas, né,
que são muito menos aterogênicas, não é
heterogênicas, não é aterogênicas, viu,
Eliseu?
Então isso é confirmado pela literatura
recente que mostra que quando essa
relação HDL triglicérides, né, ou seja,
triglicérides dividido pelo HDL estiver
abaixo de dois, menos de 25% dos
pacientes têm partículas pequenas e
densas de LDL.
Então, com triglicides estão baixos, o
LDL ele elevado de 204,
provavelmente representa partículas
grandes, menos propensas a oxidação e
penetração na parede interna dos vasos,
né, o endotélio. Então, o que a gente
preocupa mais é como sisteína de 11, que
tá acima de 10.
Então tem estudos recentes que mostram
que valores acima de 9 ou 10 já aumentam
significativamente o risco
cardiovascular
e mortalidade total. Então teve um
estudo coreano de de 2024 que demonstrou
um formato em U da mortalidade, então
com pontos de inflexão em 9,1 microles
por litro. Então, valores entre 11 e 15
de homocisteína aumenta o risco de
eventos cardiovasculares em 28 a 90%
comparado a valores abaixo deve. Então,
para uma mulher de 66 anos fisicamente
ativa, eu focaria eh primeiro em
otimizar essa mocisteína. A gente faz
isso com vitaminas betiladas do complexo
B, metifolato, meticobolamina e P5P, né?
Fosfato de cinco piridoxal.
As doses podem ser de mitifolato por
volta de 1 mg, miticobalamina também por
volta de 1 mg e o fosfato perridoxal por
volta de 50 mg ao dia. E se não baixar,
a gente pode adicionar a
trimetiloglicina, na, fósfatidolina,
pode acrescentar a creatina, tem vários
elementos que que ajuda a baixar a
cisteína.
E é importante também uma avaliação de
proteína C reativa ultrassensível para
avaliar inflamação e potencial de
oxidação desse LDL. Pedir também o LPA,
né, para estratificação de risco
genético e considerar se é necessário,
de acordo com o histórico familiar, um
teste de calusficação coronariana. Seria
uma angotomografia coronariana para ver
essa carga aterosclerótica.
Seria interessante pensar numa proteção
contra a oxidação das partículas de LDL
com a vitamina E, né, os tocotrienois
e também com enzima Q10 e vitamina C.
Então, o HDL de 75 ele é protetor e a
atividade física regular ajuda na
funcionalidade das partículas.
Então, a paciente tá no caminho certo
com exercício quatro vezes por semana.
Eliseu, confirma para mim se você tá me
escutando, tá? porque eu recebi uma
mensagem suas 7 da noite.
Hã, mas eu acho que tá tudo bem, mas
como teve essa queda da internet, eu
queria a confirmação.
Então, nessa paciente não é obrigatório
entrar com estatina só porque o LDL
colesterol é alto, tá? E se bem que é
muito difícil de convencer os
cardiologistas
a respeito disso.
Mas uma estratégia poderia centrar com
uma dose baixa de estatina.
junto eh com
mudança estilo de vida. Bem, a próxima
pergunta. Uma vez tomando estatina e
obtendo melhoria no nível de colesterol,
é possível parar de tomar?
Sim, possível é, mas temos que analisar
o contexto aí, tá? Essa é uma questão
fundamental,
surge com muita frequência na prática
clínica e demonstra um equívoco que
algumas pessoas tem na abordagem
convencional ao tratamento colesterol. A
literatura médica mais recente, ela
confirma categoricamente que ao
descontinuar estatinas, acontece um
fenômeno de rebote rápido e
potencialmente perigoso. Então, se essa
pessoa não mudou o estilo de vida, só tá
dependendo do remédio para poder
controlar o LDL, seja o que for, isso é
péssimo, porque quando para a estatina
tem esse efeito rebote. Então, estudos
publicados em 2024 e 2025 demonstram que
dentro de apenas 4 dias após a suspensão
da estatina, o LDL colesterol aumenta em
30% e entre 7 a 15 dias atinge picos de
79% acima dos valores basais durante o
tratamento. É muito importante então
associar o estilo de vida para não ter
esse rebote, esse aumento rápido depois
da suspensão.
Então, não existe um efeito residual
protetor da estatina. É o mito. O
colesterol volta aos níveis
pré-tratamento muito rapidamente e pode
até ultrapassar os níveis iniciais.
Então, o ponto crucial que poucos
médicos entendem é que o problema real
não está na elevação do colesterol total
ou mesmo do LDL colesterol como números
absolutos. E o velador perigo, como já
falamos aqui e como estabeleceu o Dr.
Josef Sinatra, está no aumento das
partículas pequenas e densas de LDL que
oxidam. E é na oxidação dessas
partículas que acontece o problema de
sequestração e inflamação na parede do
endotélio.
Então, quando você para a estatina, se
você não mexeu em mais nada, não
melhorou o estilo de vida, não melhorou
nada, além do aumento quantitativo do
LDL, há uma deterioração
qualitativa das partículas, tornando-se
menores, mais densas e mais suscetíveis
à oxidação.
Então, as estatinas quando funcionam,
elas também têm um efeito pleotrópico. O
que que quer dizer isso? efeitos
antiframatórios, estabilizam placas e
melhoram a função endoterial. Então,
quando você suspende de uma vez, pode
perder esses benefícios e cria uma
situação de risco cardiovascular
aumentado. Então, eu sugeriria o quê?
Não suspender, mas sim baixar a dose da
estatina para uma dose bem baixa, que
não levaria a efeitos colaterais junto
com as mudanças de estilo de vida.
Então, falando em mais números, a taxa
de recidiva da deslipidemia após
suspensão é de aproximadamente 80% dos
pacientes em estudos controlados. Em
paciente diabético tipo 2, esse número
pode ser ainda maior. Então é mais
preocupante ainda estudos que mostram
aumento de eventos cardiovasculares e
mortalidade,
especialmente pacientes com síndrome
coronariana aguda ou AVC recente. Então,
respondendo objetivamente, não é
interessante parar simplesmente de tomar
de uma vez, sem uma mudança
importante do estilo de vida,
só porque houve melhora dos números de
colesterol. Então, esse efeito
farmacológico puro, né, é dependente da
continuidade do uso, tá? A suspensão
deve ser deve ser considerada apenas
situações em que houve suficientemente
melhora do estilo de vida em situações
também específicas quando você teve uma
transição para outras estratégias
terapêuticas que abordem o problema real
que é a qualidade das partículas de LDL,
como já comentamos na pergunta anterior,
com uso de antioxidantes,
como eu comentei, uso da coenzima Q10,
os tocotrienóis,
Então, a gente tem que pensar num
maneira mais abrangente. Então, se a
mudança feita no estilo de vida foi
suficientemente intensa, essa pessoa
pode reduzir a dose da estatina e num
prazo mais longo pode até suspender se
tiver tudo OK, tá? Uma estratégia que eu
uso muito é a associação de dose mais
baixa de estatina junto com outros
ultracêuticos mais saudáveis, como é o
caso extrato de bergamota, né, o
bergavite
ou
também o uso da berberina e o uso também
do exanicotinato de nozitol.
A Rosa tá dizendo aqui: "Vi que perdi o
início da live, depois vou ver o início
da sua resposta". Não é tranquilo. Como
a internet que caiu, a gente
praticamente teve que repetir boa parte
da resposta da primeira pergunta.
Bem, próxima pergunta. Doutor, em vídeo
recente a respeito de vitamina C,
considerando uma ingestão de 500 mg três
vezes ao dia, poderia trazer algum risco
de formação de cálculos renais? A
resposta rápida é se tiver bem
hidratado, não.
E no caso de estar gripado ou gripada,
qual seria a quantidade recomendada
paraa utilização apenas durante a
doença?
Então vamos lá, vamos analisar os dados
científicos mais recentes em relação ao
risco de cálculos renais com a dose de
1500 mg diário que eu mencionei no
vídeo, né? são 500 mg três vezes ao
vídeo, três vezes ao dia. Os estudos
mostram que o risco existente
eh real, né? É real esse risco,
principalmente para homens, mas é bem
menor para mulheres. Na prática, o que
observa que pessoas adequadamente
hidratadas
não tem esse risco ou esse risco é muito
baixo. Mas vamos falar disso tudo aqui.
Uma metaanálise 2024 publicada no
European Urology Open Science
teria confirmado que doses superiores a
1 g de vitamina C aumentaria o risco de
nefrolitis, ou seja, pedra no rim em
homens, mas não necessariamente
mulheres. O mecanismo estaria na questão
do aumento do oxalato urinário, já que
parte da vitamina C metabolizada em
oxalato pelos índice. No entanto, temos
que contextualizar esse risco. Para
pessoas, pacientes com histórico de
cálculos renais ou predisposição
familiar, eu recomendaria começar com
doses menores de vitamina C, 500 mg e
fazer um controle com exame de oxalato
urinário de 24 horas. fazer um exame de
urina de 24 horas após algumas semanas
de uso nessa dose de 500 mg dia. Então,
pra maioria das pessoas sem fatores de
risco, 100 mg divididos em três tomadas
representam um risco muito baixo, na
minha opinião, se a pessoa estiver muito
bem hidratada.
Agora falando sobre a dose durante os
processos gripais, a medicina
ortomolecular tem uma abordagem bem
diferente da medicina ortodoxa. Os
estudos convencionais falam em dose de 1
a 2 g ao dia, mas nós sabemos que essa
dose tá muito a quem do necessário para
um efeito terapêutico realmente real
para essa gripe. Então, baseando nos
protocolos que eu aprendi ao longo da
minha carreira e seguindo os princípios
da medicina funcional oomolecular,
durante o quadro gripal, você pode estar
tomando 1 a 2 g a cada duas ou 3 horas
até a tolerância intestinal, que seria a
diarreia. Então, quando você tiver
diarreia leve, você reduz a dose. Então,
tem pessoas que chegam a tomar 10, 15 ou
20 g de vitamina C por poucos dias.
Lembrando que isso é uma estratégia de
curto prazo, somente pro quadro gripal
agudo e depois de 2 tr dias você vai
interromper essa megadose.
Então 2, 3 dias tomando 2 g a cada 3
horas e depois você pode reduzir para 3
a 5 g ao dia, dividido ao longo do dia
até melhorar os sintomas gripais.
E é importante você usar vitamina C de
alta qualidade, preferencialmente junto
com os flavonoides, né, o caso, por
exemplo, da quecetina, e sempre com
estômago parcialmente cheio para
melhorar a absorção e ritar e diminuir a
irritação gástrica. Então, se você tiver
acesso à vitamina C lipossomal, ela tem
uma absorção maior, mas o custo é bem
mais alto. Então, lembrando que a minha
vida da vitamina C no sangue é de apenas
30 minutos quando usamos doses altas. E,
por isso a divisão em múltiplas tomadas
é importante tomar cada 3 horas.
E estudos mostram que os mamíferos de
grande porte produzem naturalmente 3 a
15 g por dia nos organismos, o que nos
dá uma base biológica para essas doses
terapêuticas.
Para quem tem receio de pedra nos rins
de cálculo renal, uma alternativa
durante a gripe é aumentar
significativamente a hidratação e usar o
magnésio junto, 300 a 400 mg dia, porque
o magnésio inibe a cristalização de
oxalate cálcio, além de manter a
vitamina K2 para otimizar o metabolismo
do cálcio.
Vamos pra próxima pergunta aqui.
Doutor, ainda com base em seu vídeo mais
recente sobre vitamina C, do ponto de
vista da medicina automolecular e não
apenas nas quantidades padronizadas pela
medicina convencional. E ainda de
maneira bastante simplificada, eu
poderia considerar que a quantidade mais
correta de consumo de vitamina seria
algo em torno de 10 vezes o valor da
RDA.
Não dá para generalizar todas as
vitaminas assim, tá?
Não existe uma regra fixa de 10 vezes
RDA,
OK? Mas sim, você tem que pensar em
doses bem mais altas do que as doses
estabelecidas pelos órgãos oficiais.
Então vamos explicar isso com dados
concretos de literatura.
O Instituto Linus Paulin, é uma
referência em ortomolecular e pesquisa
nutricional, demonstrou que paraa
vitamina C, que na RDA é de apenas 90 mg
para homens e 75 mg para mulheres, eles
não concordam. Eles recomendam 400 mg
diários para adultos saudáveis. Isso já
é cerca de quatro a cinco vezes a RDA.
Então não é 10 vezes, né?
E isso ainda pode ser considerado
conservador, porque a vitamina C é muito
segura. E o próprio Linus Paulin
recomendava 2 g diários como prevenção.
Pra vitamina E, a RDA é 15 mg, mas o
Instituto Linos Paul recomenda 200 mg,
que é mais de 13 vezes a RDA. E estudos
mostram segurança com até 16 unidades
diárias. Então, se for tocatoria, você
pode tomar tranquilamente 100, 200 por
dia, que eu acho que é a versão mais
potente, mais segura paraa vitamina D,
embora a RDA seja 600 a 800 por dia,
você sabe que pouquíssimas pessoas
conseguem ter níveis adequados com essa
dose e a gente trabalha mais na faixa de
2.000, 4.000, 5.000 e às vezes 10.000
1000 unidades por dia, dependendo da
situação. Então, seguramente para uma
pessoa que não tá ainda fazendo
acompanhamento médico, ela pode tomar
2.000 por dia até ela ter acesso aos
exames para verificar como é que tá a
vitamina D.
O que acontece é que cada vitamina tem
uma relação diferente entre a dose de
sobrevivência, que é a dose mínima RDA e
a dose ótima. Algumas podem ser de três
a cinco vezes e outras 10 a 20 vezes.
Então não dá para generalizar número 10.
E algumas, como a vitamina C, pode
chegar 50 a 100 vezes em situações
terapêuticas, né, como eu comentei aqui
da gripe. Então a RDA ela foi criada
para prevenir doenças carenciais muito
óbvias, né, como escorbuto, né, no caso
a vitamina C, o beriber e o pelagra.
Então não foi desenhada para saúde
ótima, né? né? Então, essa diferença
entre não morrer de sede e está bem
hidratado.
Nós sabemos que cada indivíduo tem as
suas necessidades bioquímicas únicas,
tem a ver com os polimorfismos, aquelas
mutações pontuais, né, que não levam ao
organismo a ser inviável, mas que pode
aumentar a necessidade de uma vitamina
ou outra. Então, trabalhamos com faixas
de dosagem baseadas em evidências
científicas, individualização, sempre
priorizando a segurança.
Próxima pergunta.
É possível NAC potencializar o azul de
metileno? A pergunta interessante. Eu
nunca tinha recebido isso antes. Talvez
até faça um vídeo a respeito.
E eu posso responder que sim, existe o
potencial cinético entre o NAC e o azul
de metileno. Então, azul de metileno,
como é que ele atua? Ele vai atuar como
transportador alternativo de elétrons na
cadeia respiratória mitocondrial ou
cascata fosforilativa mitocondrial. Vai
redirecionar elétrons diretamente do
NADH para o citocummo C. citocromo C,
evitando vazamentos de elétrons que
geram espécies reativas de oxigênio.
Então isso aumenta a atividade do
complexo 4 da mitocôndria e promove a
respiração mitocondrial mais eficiente.
O na ele é precursor da glutatona. Vocês
sabem que glutatona é é um tripeptídeo
que é formado por ácido glutâmico,
NAC, que é a cisteína e também a
glicina. Então o NAC desses aminoácido
todos é o que tem mais dificuldade obter
na dieta. Então o NAC como precursor da
gluta ele atua restaurando os níveis de
gluta mitocondrial e isso é essencial
para proteção contra o estresse
oxidativo. Então temos estudo de 2024.
mostrando que o NAC melhora de maneira
significativa a função mitocondrial
em célula chamado oligodentrócitos.
Oligodentrócito são células de suporte
ao sistema nervoso central, de suporte
aos neurônios cerebrais.
Então, na que além de melhorar a função
mitocondrial dessas células específicas,
também tem evidências de outras células.
Então isso vale muito a pena,
especialmente quando as pessoas têm
ainda sinaagem de disfunção
mitocondrial.
Então, o que torna a combinação do NAC
com o azul de metida interessante e tem
um estudo que eu encontrei em que houve
uso específico de NAC, vitamina C e azul
de metileno em combinação para
tratamento de intoxicação por fosfato de
alumínio, mostrando efeitos benéficos
quando utilizados de maneira conjunta,
NAC, vitamina C e azul de metileno.
Então isso sugere que há uma sinergia
farmacológica real entre esses
compostos. Além disso, estudos recentes
demonstraram que a combinação de
diferentes compostos que atuam em vias
mitocondriais complementares pode gerar
efeitos cinéticos de maneira
significativa. Então, teve um trabalho
publicado em 21, 2021, que mostrou que a
combinação de glicose, ácido nicotínico
e nac
teve efeitos sinérgicos em modelo de
disfunção do complexo um mitocondrial,
melhorando o potencial de membrana
mitocondrial e reduzindo o estresse
oxidativo. Então, esse é um estudo que
foi feito, né, em modelo animal.
Portanto, é bem teórico, é bem factível
que o NAC poderia potencializar os
efeitos do azul de metileno através
desse mecanismo complementares, né?
Repetindo, o azul de metileno otimiza o
transporte de elétrons e a reprodução de
ATP e o NAC fortalece os sistemas
antioxidantes mitocondriais e restaura a
gluta e isso criaria um ambiente
mitocondrial mais favorável porque o
azul de metilena exerça os seus efeitos
de forma mais eficaz. Então é uma boa
combinação, sim. Eu acho que vale a pena
você experimentar.
Próxima pergunta. Doutor, o que que o
senhor acha do uso de estatina quando os
níveis de LDL são considerados altos
pela medicina convencional? E a
suposição é que seja uma questão
genética? Ah, é importante fazer o exame
do LPA, é importante fazer o exame da A
polipoproteína A1 e da A polipoproteína
B, ver realmente esses números e
considerar o uso de estatina em baixas
dosagens, como eu falei na pergunta
anterior, junto com outros ultracéuticos
que vão potencializar o efeito da
estatina sem precisar de doses altas.
Então, nós sabemos que a medicina
convencional trata o LDL elevado,
especialmente quando tem componente
genético, como é o caso da
hipercolesterolemia
familiar, como se fosse uma questão
matemática, simplesmente baixar o LDL,
né? Então, RDL alto significaria
estatina para a vida inteira.
A realidade, como eu já comentei mais
cedo nessa live, é muito mais complexa
do que isso, né? né? Então, já falamos
que nem todo LDL é igual, que tem o LDL
de partícula pequena e densa e tem o LDL
de partícula grande e flutuante, né, ou
fofinha, né? O Stephen Sinatra, que foi
o grande divulgador dessas informações,
desses tipos de partículas de LDL.
Então, temos que promover as partículas
grandes e flutuantes do LDL e combater
as partículas pequenas e dessas, que são
as verdadeiras vilãs, porque elas que
oxidam e causam danos na parede da
artéria.
A literatura mais recente de 2024 e 25
sobre estatinas revelam que elas reduzem
o LDL total, porém alguns estudos
demonstram que podem, na verdade,
aumentar proporção de partículas
pequenas e densas, tá? Então, o estudo
que foi publicado no PMC mostrou que a
terapia com estatinas não diminui a
proporção de LDL pequeno e denso entre
as partículas totais de LDL e pode na
verdade até aumentar. Então isso é mais
uma razão de associar o tratamento
estatina com ultracéuticos, né, que tem
outras ações.
Então, mesmo falando de questões
genéticas, especialmente a
hipercolesterolemia familiar, a minha
abordagem é sempre mais abrangente. A
gente tem que ver na prática outras
causas, né, contribuindo para o quadro:
disfunção tireidiana, disbiose,
permeabilidade intestinal excessiva,
toxicidade por metais pesados, infecções
crônicas latentes.
Então, precisamos sempre investigar de
maneira completa as causas raiz, a
função tiroidiana, não apenas o TSH
normal, o teste de hiperpermeabilidade
intestinal, os marcadores inflamatórios,
como é o caso da proteína ser reativa
ultrassensível, é a homocisteína,
como já falei, o LPA, a polipoproteína
um, a polipoproteína B e se for possível
também medir o LDL oxidado e o marcador
que chama-se LP PL. PL2, que é um
marcador de também de estresse
oxidativo, LP PL2.
E se for possível também fazer análise
avançada de lipoproteínas, que vê a
quantidade de partículas e o tamanho das
partículas, né? O fracionamento para ver
se tem o LDL pequeno e denso. É
interessante se for possível, né?
Sempre lembrando da dieta
anti-inflamatória, que pode ser a dieta
low carve, pode ser a mediterrânea
e aumentar o consumo de ômega-3,
eliminar glúten e caseína, reduzir os
carboidratos inflamatórios, os refinados
e processados, que vão aumentar os
triglicérides e também número de
partículas pequenas e densas.
Então, já falamos sobre a berberina, já
falamos sobre o estrato bergamota, já
falamos o tocotrienois,
pode ser utilizado também o exercinato
de noitol, tudo isso vai ajudar
bastante.
Lembrando que as estatinas causam
depressão de coenzima Q10, baixo
coenzima Q10 e podem afetar o
funcionamento mitocondrial, causando
fadiga e causando também dor muscular.
Bem, vamos lá. Tem as perguntas do
Eliseu aqui.
Ah, é saudável trabalhar em pé o dia
todo usando o notebook colocado sobre o
standing desk. é bem mais saudável do
que ficar sentado, Eliseu, né? Inclusive
o Dr. Josef Mercola, ele tem uma esteira
que tipo 1 a 2 km/h
que ele fica em pé trabalhando no
computador e andando nessa esteira. E é
uma coisa mais sofisticada.
Eu nem sei se dá para fazer isso no
Brasil. Eu não tenho certeza se é uma,
acho que a esteira dele, acho que é, é
uma esteira que não tem aquela parte da
frente. Não sei como é que funciona
isso, mas seria o ideal como esteira,
né? Mas já só de ficar de pé já é bem
mais saudável do que ficar sentado o dia
inteiro.
Tomar melatoninas 3 horas antes de
dormir é melhor do que tomar 2 horas
antes.
É, eu continuo sustentando isso, tá?
mesmo no caso da melatonina do
isso ali, esse artigo mesmo. É verdade.
Bem, vamos lá pro
pro artigo.
Bem, pessoal, eu quero que vocês
imaginem a seguinte cena. Uma família
indiana chega ao Canadá, malas na mão,
sonhos no coração. Nos primeiros meses,
eles ainda preparam os seus alimentos.
né, ancestrais, os daus aromáticos, os
ídiles ao vapor, temperam tudo com
cúrcuma dourada, mas aí com a correria
do dia a dia e eles começam a sofrer
influências culturais do Canadá e também
os supermercados da esquina não têm
todos os ingredientes e com o aperto do
trabalho, de repente eles param de comer
a alimentação ancestral deles e de
repente começam a comer aquele
hambúrguer congelado que parece mais
prático e ficar 3 horas preparando um
curry. E aí que a coisa fica
interessante. Um estudo fresco que foi
publicado agora em agosto de 25, esse
mês,
no NPJ Biofilms Microbioms jogou luz
numa questão que a gente meio que já
desconfiava, mas que agora tem uma
prova. Quando essas famílias mudam, né,
a alimentação tradicional para o padrão
da dieta americana, né, a chamada a
dieta, né, Standard American Diet, o
microbioma intestinal delas literalmente
muda de time. É como se as bactérias do
bem fossem sendo substituídas por outras
menos bacanas. O que mais impressiona é
que a velocidade dessa mudança é bem
rápida. Os pesquisadores acompanharam
imigrantes indianos recém-chegados ao
Canadá e descobriram que em questão de
meses, não foi anos, né, o perfil
bacteriano do intestino já começava a se
parecer mais com de um canadense nascido
lá do indiano que nunca saiu da Índia,
né? Então isso chamou a atenção dos
pesquisadores
e a segunda geração, os filhos dos
indianos que migraram,
que já nasceram no Canadá, apresentavam
um microbioma ainda mais ocidentalizado.
E os cientistas chamam isso de perda de
diversidade microbiana composta através
das gerações. Então, em bom português,
cada geração que passa vai perdendo mais
daquelas bactérias protetoras que os
ancestrais carregavam.
E aí você pode estar se perguntando,
e daí qual é o problema de ter um
microbioma mais parecido com o pessoal
do ocidente? Bem, nós sabemos que no
ocidente a diversidade microombiana é
bem menor. Estudos mostram que esse
microbioma ocidentalizado
está associado a um risco
cardiometabólico maior, né? maior doença
coronariana e metabólica, então mais
diabetes tipo dois, mais obesidade, mais
síndrom metabólica, mais doenças
inflamatórias intestinais e a lista é
grande.
Então tem uma informação que me deixou
um pouco perplexo. Os indianos que
mantiveram uma dieta rica em fibras e
alimentos tradicionais tiveram níveis
altíssimos de uma bactéria chamada
prevotela copre, que eu nem conheci essa
bactéria. E essa bactéria é especialista
em quebrar carboidratos complexos,
aqueles que vêm das leguminosas, né, dos
feijões, da fava, do grão de bico e
também de grãos integrais e vegetais
fibrosos. Então, essas bactérias
funcionam como se fosse uma usine de
processamento de fibras no intestino. E
quando a pessoa passa a comer alimentos
mais ultraprocessados,
pest food, essa tal de prevotela vai
sumindo e dá lugar a outras bactérias
que adoram um ambiente inflamado.
Então, o estudo mostrou também que junto
com a mudança das bactérias mudou também
o arsenal de enzimas que elas produzem.
Os imigrantes perderam enzimas
especializadas em degradar fibras
vegetais complexas,
né? Essas enzimas chamam-se carbohydrate
active enzymes ou na sigla CAZ, não sei
como é que eles pronunciem isso em
inglês. Então é como se o intestino
fosse perdendo as ferramentas
especializadas para processar alimentos
saudáveis.
Agora vamos falar de algo bem brasileiro
que se conecta com essa história aí dos
indianos no Canadá.
Você já reparou como nossos avós,
bisavós, tinham o hábito de comer feijão
todo santo dia? É, até hoje pra maioria
dos brasileiros é uma realidade, né?
Arroz com feijão, o clássico. Parece que
essa dupla, para quem não tem
resistência insulínica, ela é
interessante em termos de fibras. e
alimenta as bactérias do bem também.
Mas muita gente hoje em dia trocou essa
alimentação tradicional do Brasil por um
lanche rápido ou um delivery qualquer.
E não é só sobre o que a gente come, é
sobre como a comida é preparada também.
Então, os indianos tradicionalmente usam
especiarias muito interessantes, é causa
da cúrcuma, do gengibre, do cominho, e
descobriram que a curcumina, né,
interage diretamente com o nosso
microbioma. Então, ela estimula o
crescimento de bactérias benéficas e tem
um efeito anti-inflamatório poderoso.
Mas quando você come um hambúrguer
ultraprocessado, cadê a cúrcuma, né? Não
tem cúrcuma, né? E cadê as especiarias
também que não existem?
Foi tudo substituído por realçadores de
sabor artificial, corantes,
estabilizantes, emicantes, conservantes.
E falando de emocificantes,
vou te falar uma coisa que assusta.
Então, estudos recentes 2024 e 25
mostram que esses aditivos
emulsificantes
presentes nos ultraprocessados podem
aumentar a permeabilidade intestinal,
causando o famoso liquigat, um intestino
hiperpermeável.
né? Então isso é mais um favor, um fator
que fala contra o uso dos
ultraprocessados.
Então interessante é que o estudo não
encontrou essas mudanças,
né, de microbioma só comparando indianos
na Índia com indianos no Canadá. Eles
também analisaram os hábitos alimentares
de maneira detalhada. Aqueles que
mantiveram o hábito de comer dal, idle,
dosa, chapate integral, são alimentos
indianos, mesmo orando no Canadá,
conseguiram preservar melhor o
microbiôme original, né? É como se a
comida tradicional fosse um escudo
protetor.
Agora vou compartilhar com vocês algo
que eu uso muito no consultório
e se conecta com esse estudo. Quando eu
atendo pacientes que migraram de outros
países, né, brasileiros, por exemplo,
que mudaram drasticamente os hábitos
alimentares,
eu investigo a transição alimentar e
pergunto como que era a alimentação na
infância e que que a avó dele cozinhava
e quais pratos tradicionais.
a pessoa ainda prepara. E sabe o que eu
descobri? Muitos abandonaram
completamente as tradições culinárias,
achando que estavam se modernizando, mas
na verdade estavam jogando fora século
de sabedoria alimentar. Os fermentados
tradicionais, como por exemplo o coreano
quinchi, o chucurute alemão, o kefir do
leste europeu, o nosso próprio tucubã,
né, com farinha fermentada no norte,
todos eles são fontes sequíssimas de
probiótico. Então, sempre lembrando de
comer os alimentos ancestrais
fermentados.
Semana passada mesmo eu atendi uma
paciente desent de japoneses que estava
com c intestino irritável e isso tava
acontecendo durante anos e quando fomos
conversar sobre a alimentação, eu
descobri que ela havia abandonado
completamente os hábitos alimentares
ancestrais da família. Nada de
Missushiro, nada de
de Tsukemono, né? Nada de Natô, só
comida rápida, delivery e
ultraprocessados.
Então eu sugeri que ela resgatasse as
receitas da família, que ligasse paraa
mãe, para a tia e pedisse as receitas
antigas, né? Então ela teve dificuldade,
mas teve que procurar ingredientes em
lojas especializados ali na liberdade,
reaprender técnicas de fermentação, mas
em três meses a mudança foi
impressionante. Não só os sintomas
intestinais melhoraram, mas ela relatou
mais energia e melhor humor e a pele
melhorou.
Então isso me leva a um outro ponto
crucial que o estudo revelou, a
velocidade de mudança.
Os pesquisadores ficaram chocados ao ver
que mesmo em poucas semanas após a
mudança alimentar, o microbioma já
começava a se alterar. É bem rápido para
um lado e pro outro, né? Para piorar e
para melhorar.
Então, estudos mostram que apenas duas
semanas aumentando o consumo de fibras e
reduzindo ultraprocessados,
nesse caso, já é possível ver mudanças
positivas no microbioma. É como se o
nosso intestino estivesse sempre pronto
para melhorar, só esperando as condições
corretas, as ferramentas para essa
mudança que seria a comida certa. Então,
como você pode aplicar essas descobertas
na sua vida? Primeiro, não precisa virar
radical, abandonar tudo que é moderno. A
questão é o equilíbrio. Evite o máximos
ultraprocessados.
Mas se você acabar comendo, por exemplo,
um lanche no almoço, capricha no jantar
com comida de verdade, né? Arroz e
feijão, se você não tiver resistência
insulínica, saladona colorida, aquele
refogado de couve com alho. E use muito
especiarias. Eu falo cada vez mais pros
pacientes, use os temperos naturais, tá?
é ouro puro para o microbioma. Cúrcuma,
o gengibre, o alho, orégano, alecrim.
Eles são praticamente remédios e são
relativamente baratos e fáceis de
encontrar, né? Uma pitada de cúrcuma com
pimenta do reino no seu prato todo dia
já faz uma boa diferença, porque vocês
sabem que a pimenta do reino, por ter a
piperina, aumenta a absorção da cucumina
em até 2000%.
E não esqueçam de comer os fermentados,
né?
Eh, pode ser um iute fermentado,
natural, um kefir, um chucrute,
uma limonada fermentada. Tá valendo tudo
aí em termos de fermentados. Isso vai
alimentar as bactérias do bem.
E o feijão quando ele é deixado de molho
de um dia pro outro já começa um
processo de fermentação benéfico
e vai tirar também aquelas substâncias
que geram os gases com mais frequência
os antinutrientes.
Questione os rótulos. Cuidado que ele pô
integral industrializado, cheio de
conservantes.
Não é a mesma coisa que um pão integral
caseiro ou de padarinha artesanal sem
glúten, né? Aquele suco de caixinha
natural não é a mesma coisa que a fruta
em natura. O ultraprocessamento rouba da
comida não só nutrientes, mas também a
matriz alimentar complexa que nossas
bactérias intestinais reconhecem e sabem
processar.
E tem uma coisa que o estudo mostrou que
é fascinante. As bactérias intestinais
têm memória evolutiva. Elas evoluíram
junto com os nossos ancestrais ao longo
de milhares de anos. Então, quando você
come um alimento tradicional, é como se
estivesse falando a língua que elas
entendem. Quando você come
ultraprocessado, cheio de aditivos, é
como se estivesse falando grego para
elas literalmente não sabe o que fazer
com aquilo.
Então, é aceitável comer ultraprocessado
de vez em quando, mas não torne isso
regra, torne exceção, tá?
Cuidado quando o hambúrguer congelado
aparecer mais na sua mesa do que o arroz
com feijão ou a carne não processada.
E vou contar para vocês uma curiosidade.
O estudo mostrou que os imigrantes que
mantiveram pelo menos 30% da dieta com
alimentos tradicionais, né, ancestrais,
conseguiram preservar muito melhor a
diversidade do microbioma,
ou seja, não precisa ser 100%
tradicional. O texto já faz uma grande
diferença.
Se você for uma pessoa saudável, você
pode utilizar o princípio da regra 8020.
Se 80% do tempo você come comida de
verdade, minimamente processada, rica em
fibras e temperada com especiarias, os
20% de escorregadas não vão
provavelmente destruir o seu microbioma.
Lembrar que o chá de gengibre é bom para
enjô, o alho é bom para aumentar a
imunidade. Então, esses alimentos que a
sabedoria ancestral já tinha como
terapêuticos, a gente cada vez confirma
mais.
Minha sugestão de hoje para vocês,
conversem com os mais velhos da família,
resgatem receitas, aprendam técnicas
tradicionais de preparo e quando forem
ao supermercado, pense não só no que
vocês estão comprando, mas no que vocês
estão deixando de o comprar. E cada
escolha alimentar é um voto por um tipo
de microbioma que vocês querem cultivar.
Bem, vamos para mais perguntas aqui.
Ao tomar banho, uma mulher deve enxaguar
a região de íntima quanto tempo depois
de passar o sabonete específico para
candidase?
Vamos colocar aqui uns 5 minutos, tá,
Eliseu?
Qual exame fazer para medir a
contaminação de microplásticos no
organismo? Esse exame não existe ainda,
é só em laboratório de pesquisa.
Eh, tem umas perguntas novas aqui no
questionário. Agora que eu fui ver aqui.
Como usar azul de metilena de forma
correta? É só você mandar manipular,
vai depender do seu peso, mas uma dose
segura é 30 mg de azul de metilheno,
você pode tomar de uma a duas vezes ao
dia, tá?
Linos paur tomava 16 g de vitamina C.
por dia. Disseram para ele que foi por
isso que ele pegou o câncer. Com certeza
não foi.
Só que eu não tomaria 16 g de vitamina C
todos os dias, não. Tá.
Ele respondeu: "Pelo contrário, a
vitamina C retardou retardou o câncer. O
que que você acha disso?" Eu acho que é
muito simplista, né? Só a vitamina C
sozinha não ia resolver essa questão do
câncer, não.
Bem, acho que já respondi essas
perguntas aí do questionário. Boa noite,
Dr. T. Ana Paula.
Sim, óleo Negro é muito bom. Pena que
ele é caro.
Você se refere ao LDL oxidado? Sim, tava
referindo ao LDL oxidado. Exatamente.
Falência múltipla de ógos, Eliseu, é o
evento final de qualquer morte, tá? Se
você não morreu de tiro no meio da rua
ou atropelado, se você for parar no
hospital com qualquer doença, o final da
sua vida vai ser falência múltipla de
órgãos, tá? É um termo extremamente
genérico, que não significa
absolutamente nada, tá? Porque qualquer
doença que sai do controle, começa a
matar a pessoa, vai dar a falência
múltipla de órgãos.
Aliás, se pensar bem, até você morrer
com tiro no meio da rua ou atropelado,
vai dar falência múltipla de órgãos.
Então não quer dizer absolutamente nada
isso daí.
Eh, sim, Eliseu, existe uma situação na
neurologia clínica, tá? Chama chama-se,
eu esqueci o nome agora, esse é um
negócio que eu li há muito tempo atrás,
o pessoal chama de projeção astral, né?
Mas na neurologia tem um termo
que é,
não me lembro agora,
mas enfim, eles acham que essa situação
de projeção astral não é real e que
seria uma manifestação de um problema
neurológico, tá? Mas já vai depender da
interpretação de cada um. Acho que é
cataplexia. Cataplexia, eu lembrei.
Cataplexia que eles chamam.
Tá? Então aí tem essa
discussão aí. Tá bom pessoal, estamos
aqui com 50 minutos de live, então eu
vou encerrar até para essa live ficar
mais fácil de ser vista por quem está
assistindo depois, tá? Um abraço, um
beijo no coração de vocês, até a
próxima.